jojo was geht user max und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video zusammen
mit luca ist schon wieder dort wir
machen wollte etwas sehr lustiges würde
ich sagen wir kneten youtuber ihr seht
schon jede menge knete am start
zwei kameras eine ist vom werten herrn s
und der wird uns jetzt gleich sagen
wenige bauern sollen dann haben wir
eineinhalb sekunden eines kompletten
eineinhalb minuten zeit tobt und
anfangen zu bauen und bauen uns ein oder
youtube sagen uns den allerersten 321
wie viel raum insgesamt drei youtube
angeklickt
du musst dir schnell sein also ihr seid
alle 20 sekunden sind auch ja ist
deswegen ich habe du musst einfach so
ein strichmännchen bauen immer dann
packst du accessoires dazu die dann
entscheiden sind dafür fällig die sich
ja ok 50/50 sie können noch bis in 1
racing im gesicht
was gibt's noch was gesucht vergibt nein
das lang mitglied bist du also bild wir
klären jetzt jeweils ja das hier meine
damen und herren ist mein abschlepp okay
die orange fahrt erklärt sich von selbst
weil wir hatten keine andere hautfarbe
quasi dann habe ich hier ein rotes t
shirt bzw ein rotes long tanktops sind
ja sehr stilvoll wie man in diesen
kreisen weiß und deshalb trägt apa/red
auch immer welche rote sneaker im wert
von einem tierpark alter viel und hier
die dekabank
und da haben wir an lukas gehört ein
haufen elend
ich habe die schwarzen haare die
natürlich hoch gesetzt gesicht breit
nichts zu sagen ich scheiße dann habe
ich die goldkette die goldkette und hier
habe ich daher waren in seinen videos
die sneaker nie sieht und die nur im
hintergrund stehen habe ich dir einfach
plötzlich geriet am ende den kommentaren
entscheiden was euch am besten gefallen
hatten welcher youtuber am liebsten oder
am echten außer so leute wir starten
jetzt mit youtube nur dann genutzt
wir fangen jetzt an es gibt uns den
nächsten youtuber luca rossetti bleiben
jetzt gehen wir national okay ich will
dass ihr jetzt 30 sekunden ein
casey aber ich kann das noch gar nicht
kommentieren gerade gegen kommentieren
ich wie baut man soll ja auch gar nicht
kommentieren weil denn wir kommentieren
dann kann ja der jeweils andere sich
immer so ein bisschen ab schauen und das
ist natürlich nicht im sinne des
erfinders deshalb leute nicht so viel
kommentar es könnte natürlich ein
bisschen
du kannst ein bisschen alsbald in noch
relativ klassisch las ich ganz einfach
mit orange lose arbeitete schon mit
mehreren farben orange und weil das alte
und das neue spaß in einer figur schon
die ersten opfer handeln gebaut so gott
oder 30 sekunden zeit fahren
ich weiß sonst alle perspektiven ist
damit mit dem wir haben noch zehn
sekunden aufschlag ab sogar kurz
bisherige auf schlag drauf stand ein
bisschen auf einen weiteren leckerbissen
sekunden geht's okay
während jetzt auf 10,3 im winter 61
schloss schluss schluss dass das ist
heute das war kraft jetzt noch eine
kurze verlängerung weil wir beide noch
nicht ganz fertig war ich erkläre erst
mal wieder hier keine haare muss ich
sagen ist mir nicht gelungen die
sonnenbrille hier ist auch nicht so
perfekt dafür eine working kamera ist
typisch casey und hier jeder der
casetech erkennt dass boost bord jetzt
am ende so ein bisschen drauf geballert
und hier ist lukas der sieht auch extrem
gut aus die ich hab halt bei den haaren
drauf geachtet er ist halt immer so wie
beim server oder so da diese auf die
andere seite geparkt
deswegen hab ich das jetzt so gemacht
und bei den hofer habe ich darauf
geachtet weil er nimmt die hosen
hochgekrempelt deswegen habe ich hier
vor den zwischen schulen und hose noch
mal so ein bisschen haut gemacht und
schuhe trägt dieses schwarzen schafs
oder so deswegen ich bin du hast gute
elemente mit der blauen kamera dem
pustet bord aber ich bin irgendwie rolex
mit ihm schon den haaren für mich wissen
und entschieden aber die zuschauer
dürfen die zuschauer ist entscheidend
dass klar enthält weizen also des
kletterwalds insgesamt so lautet der
letzte youtuber wird im 3 21 von uns
gebaut
nämlich als tränen
so sagen letzte runde drei ich hab mir
die taktiken gehe angewandt werde es
unglaublich verändert auch kneter kraft
erinnern der das ist sehr warm
meist arbeitet er schon vorher mit
groben frau hätte aber erst mal getrennt
pink orange der russischen beauty schon
die ersten gesichtsmerkmale manchmal
neigen 40 sekunden bleiben dort ihr
glück immer dutch günstig holte drei
minuten 23 uhr leiten den der mann
gesagt oder machen wir drei haben wir
doch noch ein bisschen mehr zeit leute
bestimmt hier die beiden drei minuten
blockiert
damit bleibt sich jetzt noch eine minute
und 20 sekunden übrig lachs gibt es hier
schon halten
beim aktivieren klamotten bisher auch
stark aus blues steht für die luft schon
am start war max fehlt noch ein bisschen
die beine
die haben ja ich bin der verband wollen
die beine gemacht max von der letzten
zeit super ist bisschen relaxter und
seine baby ähnlich wie dein case wieder
mit dem etwas größeren kopf der
gegenwart proportionen bisschen anders
richter hätten 500 frisur selbst was ich
ihr habt noch 5 sekunden
die zeit ist ich bin selber sehr
interessant wie möglich fahren so für
die auf youtube hilft okay manchmal
zuerst erklären also wie wir ihn
natürlich blonde haare wir hatten jetzt
nicht so viel von dem gelben wer
deswegen konnte ich jetzt nicht so krass
ausweiten gesicht habe ich nicht zu
sagen blaupausen nasenlänge
bei ihr so ein bisschen schwindel
festgestellt bei den ein oder anderen
produkten ziehung auf jeden fall dann
haben wir natürlich die teams am start
weil weibliche youtube drin ist dann hat
sich das bio produkte der hand dessen
freund julian den sie ja immer so ein
bisschen so die beiden
den konnte ich leider nicht mehr hat
leider nicht die hosen an sonne das
würde ja sonst ganz gut passen stimmt so
und das hier ist meine babys findet ihr
auf die haare dich ganz stolz muss ich
sagen deine augen
malta ist ob die kamera erkennt das
gesicht von der puppe ohne scheiß
die gewichts erkennt leute über meinem
baby bekommt so also auf jeden fall hier
ein rosa kleid weil sehr mädchenhaft
erfahrungs versteht sich blonde haare
ich dazu sagen ich habe jetzt weniger
erkennungsmerkmal dafür bin ich so ja
das overall in produkte also die
menschlichkeit bin ich ganz zufrieden
mit jahre ich würde aber sagen
ihr entscheidet wer gewonnen hat
schreibt aber in die kommentare was ihr
glaubt man weiß was man diesen videos
hat viel spaß gemacht zu filmen und wir
sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal wieder
macht's gut